have you ever been walking on the beach
and happened upon a tide pool suddenly
you find an entire world contained in
that little pool of water little
creatures swimming around and going
about their lives completely oblivious
to the giant watching them from above
there's also something incredible about
that the way whole worlds can exist
inside something so small in the central
sahara desert the scp foundation
discovered a tiny world of their own
like nothing anyone had ever seen before
scp-6
also known as the flat earth
scp-6011 is a circular area hanging
about five centimeters in the air the
radius of the area spans roughly 500
meters and is buried
meters below the ground within a deposit
of limestone the scp exists as a
two-dimensional plane three-dimensional
objects passing through as if they were
not there at all all the materials found
within scp-6011 both organic and
inorganic resemble their
three-dimensional counterparts there are
a wide variety of living organisms
within scp-6011
designated scp-6011-1
the smallest instance of
scp-6011-1 resembles ordinary
earth-based single-celled organisms the
most notable species of scp-611-1
is referred to as planar homonym the
closest thing scp-6011 has to human
beings members of planet homonym
resemble the side profile of a human
with a visible head that includes a
brain a nose and an eye they also have
distinct muscular lymphatic respiratory
digestive nervous endocrine
cardiovascular urinary and reproductive
systems the only way for plantar homonym
to move is via several cilia-like
structures that they can also use to
pick up objects dr mcallis was assigned
to head the research into scp-6011 and
its various residents in pursuit of
further knowledge of plano homonym dr
mcallis decided to select a subject to
interview about the nature of scp-6011
he settled on an educated individual
named iotis and decided to initiate
contact iotis was playing a game alone
in this office when dr mcallis played a
short high-pitched noise on a speaker
suspended five centimeters above them
startled by the sound iotis reacted
calling out barton when dr mcallis spoke
iotis was immediately perplexed and
frightened unable to see where his voice
was coming from he moved around the room
feeling the walls searching for the
source of the mysterious voice as dr
mcallis insisted that they move to the
north and stop looking iotas threatened
to call the police accusing dr mcallis
of being a thief who had invaded his
home dr mcallis attempted to calm iotis
down reminding him that his yelling
would disturb his son and daughter this
only upset the subject further and he
accused michals of being a stalker in
addition to a thief finally dr mcallis
was able to subdue the subject by
insisting that he was not a thief or a
stalker but a messenger he promised no
harm would come to iotis or his family
if they would just listen to what he had
to say michalis identified himself as a
doctor bonding with iotis over their
shared education iotis requested that
mcallist show himself and since he was
unable to do so he briefly lowered a
mechanical piston into the surface of
scp-6011 though michalis was unable to
cross into scp-6011 this allowed him to
introduce a physical presence into the
area after their conversation iotis
agreed to participate in another
interview this particular conversation
was cut short when two police officers
approached the house after noise
complaints from the neighbors hayatus
called out to michalis as he left
referring to him as angel following this
initial contact and the interview that
ensued dr mcallis and his team performed
several other interviews with iotis as
more information was collected via
observation and conversation michalis
decided to put together a seminar and a
q a with junior researchers at the
foundation regarding the details of
scp-6011
during this seminar dr mcallis explained
the nature of scp-6011
and its discovery it was first happened
upon by italian colonial forces in 1912.
at the time they thought it was an
extended form of the cave system but the
foundation knew better after introducing
the junior researchers to scp-6011
michalis provided more information on
iotis himself he made it clear that
iotis is not to be mocked for assuming
michalis to be an angel explaining it
this way imagine someone suddenly
appearing within your house imagine
someone describing the direct shape of
your insides while informing you what
your relative across the country is
doing would you not also cry out angel
angel where are you angel after this
introductory portion and taking a moment
to plug his book the life in plain which
was co-authored by iotis himself
michaelis opened the floor to questions
one of the junior researchers asked why
the residents of scp-6011 look so human
mike house responded with a question of
his own do they even look human or is it
natural for our brain to make
connections between vaguely
humanoid-shaped objects as we want to
feel a sense of familiarity with them
michaelis confirmed that after a
significant amount of testing
scp-6011 is definitely two-dimensional
somehow it has no width because of this
dimensional difference between scp-6011
and the ordinary world nothing should be
removed from the boundaries of the flat
world forcing a two-dimensional object
or being into our world would cause it
to either rearrange itself to fit into a
three-dimensional configuration or cause
it to split apart at best it would
become malformed at worst the item would
undergo instantaneous nuclear fission
nothing can be placed inside of scp-6011
from the outside world either
three-dimensional objects can pass
through temporarily showing only a
cross-section of the object the
foundation advises against attempting to
place any objects inside as it would
change the enthalpy of the system during
his observation of scp-16l
as well as his interviews with iotis dr
mcallis uncovered a wide variety of
facts about life inside the flat earth
the planet homonym live in a feudal
society where people are born into a
class position and the role of the
parents is passed along to their
offspring the social hierarchy is broken
down into estates the estates are
indicated by a color applied under the
skin of each person at their birth there
is no opportunity for upward mobility or
for fall from grace only to stay in the
position one is born into those of the
red estate belong to the monarchy of
scp-6011
the orange are the administrators the
yellow are priests scribes and record
keepers the green are similar to the
middle class of 18th century europe
encompassing teachers physicians lawyers
and other educated professionals blue
are merchants tradesmen and skilled
workers and purple are the manual
laborers because of the difficulty of
accomplishing tasks in only two
dimensions the upper-class citizens have
at least two servants apiece all
servants come from the estates ranked
below green because physical writing is
difficult in the boundaries of scp-6011
members of the yellowcast are trained as
voice scribes they memorize and repeat
large amounts of information such as
entire books transcriptions of speeches
or laws entertainment in scp-6011 is
largely voice-based as well with visual
theaters considered a luxury only for
the highest class citizens the
entertainment of the common people is
found in the voice theater a place where
entertainment is structured around
dialogue and the sound of artificially
created ambiance naturally the
foundation does not want any civilian
stumbling on scp-6011
though it poses no threat to humanity
knowledge of its existence could cause
chaos and could very well endanger the
inhabitants of scp-6011
site-044 was set up around scp-6011 in
order to protect it no construction is
permitted within a 10-kilometer radius
of the area under a cover story about
the libyan government blocking off the
area for conservation purposes
scp-6011 is stored in a hermetically
sealed chamber away from external
influences all interactions with
scp-6011 or any of the organisms living
within it must be approved by the head
researcher of provisional site-044
a monitoring system is set up
perpendicular to scp-6011
so that the research team can keep an
eye on the activity inside without
disturbing the residents the monitoring
system is unfortunately not without its
flaws one day there was a malfunction in
the system that caused the breakdown of
the camera rails and several metallic
components came loose and plunged into
the surface of scp-6011
there was no damage but the objects were
seen by several civilians the foundation
was concerned that the sight of massive
pieces of mysterious objects appearing
and disappearing suddenly in a public
space would cause mass panic among the
people of scp-6011 however the research
team was shocked to see the
two-dimensional people carrying on with
their ordinary day-to-day lives they
performed an anti-cognitohazard
screening in order to determine what was
causing this strangely placid response
to what should have been a devastating
shock to the people they discovered a
large building hidden by a form of
visual cognito hazard shaped like an
octagon further monitoring of this
unusual building captured a voice
recording of a scribe reciting an
account of the monitor equipment
disaster soon after iotis was removed
from his home by officers that refused
to disclose what organization they were
working for all of this the building the
arrest the report of the incident was
traced to a secret organization
operating inside of scp-60
known as the doctors of the church the
group was made up of yellow and orange
estate members with a small selection of
green blue and purple field agents the
research team could not help but notice
how similar the doctors of the church
are to the foundation itself their
mission statements are very much the
same upholding the veil of secrecy
between the unusual and the population
they have sworn to protect while working
to understand the anomalies that they
are trying to conceal all
three-dimensional interlopers are
scrubbed from the public consciousness
or hidden from the people at large
further research indicated that the
incident would have completely destroyed
6011 if the doctors of the church had
not worked to deploy reality anchors to
keep the baseline reality of the world
intact dr mcallis wrote about this group
affectionately nicknamed the little
foundation saying when i look at them i
see well us and a little crumb of
limestone falling from the ceiling of
the car store bugs somehow making its
way onto the surface of scp-6011 phasing
in and out of existence must have
terrified them and so they found a way
to conceal all that was illogical from
the general public as did we the reality
of scp-6011 raises some fascinating if a
bit troubling questions what dimensions
are there that we have no knowledge of
just as the two-dimensional beings
cannot conceive of us what
four-dimensional beings five-dimensional
beings and so on might be out there that
we can't begin to wrap our heads around
to a creature with no concept of a third
dimension creatures that exist within
our world seem like angels or even gods
perhaps the things in this world we
cannot explain are simply creatures that
exist in more dimensions than we are
able to conceive of truly there may be
no difference between the little
foundation and the scp foundation that
we know looking down at the residents of
scp-6011 and all that they think they
know might encourage us to feel superior
instead it should make us curious and
perhaps even make us afraid of what we
might be unable to understand dr mcallis
summarized his thoughts on scp-6011 in
its file we had prior interactions with
entities that claimed to originate from
higher geometrical dimensions yet our
mind was never really capable of
understanding them where we stand we
have the capability to imagine the lives
of those in the two-dimensional space
sadly the same cannot be said for our
understanding of the four-dimensional
reality it is often said that the human
brain is like a computer so just like a
computer can never completely emulate a
machine more advanced than itself so do
we lack the ability to understand higher
dimensions to a creature outside of our
understanding we are the citizens of the
flat earth shuffling back and forth
unable to see that which lies beyond now
go check out scp-999 the tickle monster
and scp-978 desire camera for more safe
but scintillating as cps